former Fox News host Bill O'Reilly used
his podcast last night to fire back at a
New York Times report on payouts for
sexual harassment claims the time says
that six women receive settlements
totaling about forty five million
dollars from O'Reilly or 21st century
fox or Reilly says he is mad at God over
misconduct allegations and her Werner's
here with how he is hitting back and a
good morning good morning Bill O'Reilly
says he wants this story to go away but
went public to defend himself telling
those listening he did nothing wrong
anybody who doesn't like me will believe
all the stuff that the smear merchants
put out because they want to believe it
Bill O'Reilly fired back against sexual
harassment allegations last night on his
podcast am i mad at God yeah I'm mad at
him I wish I had more protection the New
York Times reported O'Reilly agreed to
pay former Fox News legal analyst lease
wheel a stunning 32 million dollar
settlement after she claimed he
repeatedly sexually harassed her she
later signed a sworn affidavit
renouncing the allegations hi I'm Bill
O'Reilly O'Reilly couldn't comment on
the settlement but said this I've never
had a complaint filed against me
anywhere by anyone statements like that
drew this response from former Fox News
host megyn kelly o'reilly suggestion
that no one ever complained about his
behavior is false
i know because i complained kelly says
she sent an email to her bosses at Fox
after O'Reilly was asked about her
allegations of sexual harassment against
Roger Ailes on CBS this morning
intellectual harassment you're not
interested in sexual her I'm not
interested in basically litigating
something that is finished
that makes my network look bad okay I'm
not interested in making my network look
bad at all that doesn't interest me one
bit so apparently she complained to
someone that's not a formal complaint it
wasn't lodged with anybody I didn't even
know about it
speaking to The Times last week O'Reilly
was defiant after the interview with
microphones still recording O'Reilly
said the controversy was taking a toll
this is
it's horrible what I went through
horrible what my family went through
this is crap and you know it
yesterday O'Reilly posted thank-you
notes on his website from megyn kelly
and former fox host gretchen carlson
from the time when they work together in
kelly's note she called o'reilly a true
friend and mentor and carlson writes
thank you so much for supporting me
thank you for being my friend
well Carlson responded on Twitter to all
this saying so what still paid thirty
two million Carlson settled with Fox for
twenty million dollars after alleging
sexual harassment by former chief Roger
Ailes megyn kelly claims that she
reported o'reilly behavior to Fox before
he was ousted we reached out to the
company but have not yet heard back Nora
a lot of details there Anna thank you so
much